HEY, [bleep] YOU,
YOU PIECE OF [bleep]!
[tires screech]
[bleep] YOU!
- OH, THIS IS AMAZING.
- OKAY, THIS [bleep] IS ON.
YOU JUST [bleep]
WITH THE WRONG GUY.
WHAT THE [bleep]
IS THE MATTER WITH YOU?
- I'VE GOT YOUR BACK,
MR. MACNEIL.
- I'M TRYING TO
[bleep] DRIVE, HERE!
YOU BLOW THROUGH
THAT STOP SIGN LIKE THAT!
DON'T [bleep] DO THAT TO PEOPLE!
YOU GOT A STOP SIGN,
YOU STOP AT THE [bleep]
WHITE LINE!
- MR. MACNEIL!
- OH, YEAH.
YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
OKAY.
HEY, [bleep], IT LOOKS LIKE
SOMETHING HAPPENED
TO YOUR [bleep] TAIL LIGHT!
[glass shatters]
- [laughs]
- YEAH.
WHAT THE [bleep] HAPPENED
TO YOUR SIDE-VIEW MIRROR,
[bleep]?
[glass shatters]
- [laughs]
- LOOKS LIKE YOUR BLIND SPOT
JUST GOT A LITTLE BIGGER,
[bleep]-WIT.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO ABOUT IT?
- WHAT AM I GONNA DO ABOUT IT?
YOU FORGOT ABOUT SOMETHING.
OH, YOU FORGOT ONE MORE THING.
HEY, YOU EVER BEEN
IN A SMASH-OFF?
YOU ARE NOW.
- SMASH-OFF!
[growls]
- NO, NO,
MR. MACNEIL! NO!
- [growls]
- NO, MR. MACNEIL!
- [howls]
- STOP, MR. MACNEIL!
THAT'S MY [bleep] CAR!
- [howls]
- PLEASE, MR. MACNEIL!
I--PLEASE!
- [grunts]
- [bleep] STOP HITTING MY CAR!
- [roars]
- WHAT THE HELL, MAN?
- [bleep] YOU!
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO NOW,
[bleep]?
- I WILL END YOU!
- [bleep] [bleep],
GET IN THE CAR!
- COME ON! COME ON!
- GET IN THE CAR NOW!
OH, [bleep].
GET IN THE CAR!
- COME ON!
- [bleep] [bleep]!
OH, [bleep]!
- GET IN, GET IN, GET IN,
GET IN, GET IN!
- [screams]
- OH, [bleep].
GO! GO! GO!
- WHAT IS HE DOING?
OH, GOD!
OH, GOD, OH, GOD, OH, GOD!
- GO, GO, GO!
- OH!
- OH, [bleep].
- AS YOU CAN SEE,
ROAD RAGE
IS A CONTAGIOUS DISEASE
AND THE RECOMMENDED TREATMENT
IS GETTING THE [bleep]
OUT OF HERE!
- MR. MACNEIL, HE'S BEHIND US!
- WHAT IS HE DOING?
WHAT IS HE DOING?
- HE'S GOING TO TRY TO RAM US.
- OH!
- I'M GONNA KILL YOU
WITH MY DICK!
- OH, MY GOD.
[horn honks]
- OH, GOD!
OH, GOD!
- HE WENT OVER THE EDGE!